comment allez-vous jean marie bigard
bien de temps en temps mais pas toujours
mais des fois c'est pas mal quand même
assez souvent mais c'est pas toujours
raide
de quoi aimeriez vous nous parler ce
soir est bien de mon prochain spectacle
qui s'appelle mon psy va mieux au
comédien au comédia à partir du 15e
répondre ead
si je vous demande de me raconter un
souvenir d'enfance n'importe quel ça
serait quoi moment mon meilleur souvenir
d'enfance c'est la première fois qu'une
fille m'a attrapé les roubignoles j'ai
trouvé ça extraordinaire parce que tu
peux pas le raconter 16 un cri pas un je
me suis dit si c'est ça la vie et ben je
suis d'accord pour continuer c'est quoi
l'expérience la plus traumatisante de ta
vie ta va serrer la main
voilà plus de dix ans de ma vie c'était
de perdre mes parents mais encore une
fois je les analyse et d'une manière
puisque c'est une interview au psy je
pense que c'est les étages de la fusée
qui se détache pour que la fusée aille
plus haut
et après coup un donc trente ans plus
tard je me dis mais si j'avais pas perdu
mais mes parents jamais serait monté
rary jamais j'aurai connu
laurent baffie thierry ardisson toi non
mais c'est tout à fait les autres
personnes s'est passé un truc très sobre
tout arrive pour le mieux y compris le
plus gros des emmerdements
tu as le choix ou de l'accepter ou de
renac les études de renâcler toute ta
vie
quelque chose de mauvais qui t'es arrivé
ou alors tu peux te dire voilà une
épreuve de la franchise je suis digne de
franchir l'obstacle donc je le franchie
dès l'enfance a eu besoin d'être aimé
bah je suis arrivé en costume
ouais tous mes frères et soeurs ils sont
arrivés tout tordu le feu lui tirer
dessus de moi je suis avait pas il a
fallu digérer sur le cordon bongo je me
claque dans le mur face fut arrivé j'ai
fait et hop
oui parce que c'est le quatrième âge
était pas tellement désiré donc tu
arrivé en disant attendait mais j'étais
pas tout de suite
drôle hein c'est pour ça que je suis
c'est pour ça que je suis comique c'est
pour ça aussi que très souvent les
artistes les grands artistes des grands
créateurs et grottes créateurs ne sont
presque jamais les premiers de la
famille parce que le premier tube bluesy
toujours un petit peu tu as envie qu'ils
soient calmes toi tu as envie qu'ils
fassent pas les conneries que tu as fait
tu comprends donc le dernier comme les
les trois autres d'avant ils ont déjà
bien déblayé le terrain
le quatrième année que s'expriment plus
libre il ce besoin de choquer tulle
explique comment mais va te faire
[ __ ]
non je n'ai pas besoin je ne je ne
considère pas comme quelqu'un de
choquant a répondu non non si si à moins
qu'elle n'ait jamais torcher le cul d'un
vieux à moins qu'on ait jamais c'est des
trucs non qu'est-ce que vous avez encore
du mal à contrôler dans la vie mais
colère un bus scolaire l'injustice ouais
ouais et la colère ça j'ai du mal à
régler le curseur vite j'ai eu envie de
mourir
j'ai tout le temps un petit peu envie ça
ne plaît pas oui non même éviter une
débâcle à la vérité comme je dis dans
mon siège
j'ai vraiment pas peur de la mort j'ai
peur comme tout le monde ne souffrir que
ça dure longtemps d'avoir une déchéance
va longue et pénible et tout mais sinon
le mort si elle vient aujourd'hui elle
est la bienvenue
le plus tard sera le mieux parce que je
suis pas suicidaire mais ouais mais ça
me fait pas peur elle vient quand à
lever je l'attend cet [ __ ] là qu allez
vous enfin compris sur vous j'ai compris
que je n'étais que une toute petite
partie de l'univers qu'il fallait pas
trop s'affoler et que la vie était
vraiment un jeu et que le mieux c'était
de jouer encore vous acceptez bien ne
pas avoir d'enfant bajeux l'acceptent
en tout cas j'ai les enfants des autres
et puis d'avoir le sien n'est jamais sûr
que c'est le sien ouais si je vais dire
un truc et on fera un contrôle sur le
sur l'ensemble de la planète au cbc rick
s'est passé ces mamans sur pas peut-être
très fier on peut toujours adopter les
enfants des autres et les filiales
absolument par exemple ça a déjà été
tenté par une aventure avec un homme
non franchement non c'est un truc de c1
c'est physique
j'suis pas je suis pas contre un an des
fois on s'embrasse quand on fait les
cons on s'embrasse sur la bouche avec la
langue on le fait un coup tous les deux
c'est cet attrait pour le sexe la taille
du sexe sur vos affiches de spectacles
etc s'est trahi pas une angoisse par
rapport à la taille réelle à votre sexe
nous non parce que c'était vraiment pour
rigoler j'ai mis des balles de tennis gg
1 sec ce qui est énorme a refait j'en
suis assez content pourquoi vous avez
besoin de toucher les couilles tout le
temps jean-marie mais pourquoi tu dis ça
sur marjah